it could have been so different when she
came to power in July 2016 the second
female Prime Minister knew exactly what
she wanted her Premiership to be defined
by if you're just managing I want to
address you directly I know you're
working around the clock I know you're
doing your best and I know that
sometimes life can be a struggle the
government I lead will be driven not by
the interests of the privileged few but
by yours instead it would be consumed by
one thing only breakfast something to
resume didn't even vote for theresa
brazier was a vicar's daughter with a
strong sense of duty and public service
she met her future husband Philip at
Oxford University describing him as her
rock when she lost both parents by the
age of 25 many students think they're
going to end up doing great things and
very few of them ever achieve it it's
it's it's noteworthy that here is
someone who who was never flashy who was
never boastful who actually did end up
doing the top job and that's that's
perhaps a lesson to future generations
in 1997 as a landslide of Blair Wright
sent at the House of Commons Theresa May
was elected to the SAF Tory seat of
Maidenhead she ruffled feathers as party
chairman there's a lot we need to do in
this party of ours our base is too
narrow and so occasionally are our
sympathies you know what some people
call us the nasty party after more than
a decade in opposition she became the
most senior woman in David Cameron's
government tourism a was to become the
longest-serving Home Secretary for more
than a hundred years and not afraid to
make a few enemies along the way so
please for your sake and for the
thousands of police officers who work so
hard every day this crying wolf has to
stop that's a bigger storm was brewing
we will give the British people a
referendum with a very simple in or out
choice in the referendum it was supposed
to stop the Conservatives banging on
about Europe Theresa May was known as
the submarine a
main campaigner who rarely surfaced my
judgement as Home Secretary is that
remaining a member of the European Union
means we will be more secure from crime
and terrorism Sky News is in a position
to call this election and Sky News is
projecting that the UK has voted out the
British people have made a very clear
decision to take a different path and as
such I think the country requires fresh
leadership to take it in this direction
after a bitterly divisive campaign the
Conservative Party reached four
stabilities as her rivals crumbled away
Theresa May emerged as the unchallenged
prime minister untested by a leadership
campaign respected rather than liked
Treatise bloody difficult woman but you
and I were from Brussels she said would
soon find out just how bloody difficult
she could be brexit means brexit and
we're going to make a success of it
brexit knees brexit I'm very clear
bricks it does mean brexit as he says we
will make a success of it as Prime
Minister Teresa may try to focus on
those burning in justices if you have a
mental health problem people are more
likely to try to avoid you we must get
over this stigma but she was boxed in by
brexit and her own red lines I want to
be clear what I am proposing cannot mean
membership of the single market when
people write a history of brexit though
one decision was perhaps the most
fateful of all I have just chaired a
meeting of the cabinet where we agreed
that the government should call a
general election to be held on the 8th
of June then the campaign started strong
and stable strong and stable strong and
stable strong and stable drawn and
stable strong and stable strong a stable
leadership but after a u-turn on social
care everything changed nothing has
changed
nothing has changed good morning you're
watching boat 2017 the results live on
Sky News
6:00 in the morning and we start with
breaking news that there will be a hung
parliament with the Conservatives losing
their majority that question would haunt
the rest of her Premiership for the
prime minister driven above all by a
sense of public service did not quit
worse was to come after the Grenville
fire tragedy mrs. may was criticized for
being distant from the victims created
record numbers of jobs the conference
speech that was the place to relaunch
her Premiership Dinka quite to plan and
then things really started falling apart
the woman who cut her teeth at the Home
Office was at her most prime ministerial
when dealing with threats to national
security such as the novice shock attack
in Salisbury to those who seek to do us
harm
my message is simple you are not welcome
here there was transatlantic diplomacy
to navigate and a few rare moments of
levity but praxis ensured that for the
most part this wasn't a woman having the
time of her
[Applause]
her first attempt to solve the brexit
conundrum was known as the checkers plan
initially signed off by a reluctant
cabinet but factions were forming
just days later the Foreign Secretary
quit
I said time for a real leadership run as
did the brexit secretary by Christmas
for some conservative back benchers it
was time for another resignation the
Prime Minister's I think coup is when
you use illegitimate procedures to try
and overturn somebody who is in office
this is working through the procedures
of the Conservative Party it is
therefore entirely constitutional but
the woman famous for her resilience
clung on change of leadership at this
point isn't going to make the
negotiations any easier and it's not
going to change the parliamentary
arithmetic what it will do what it will
do is bring in a degree of uncertainty
her deal failed to get through
Parliament multiple times the nose the
nose the nose have it and despite
promising to leave on the 29th of March
she was forced back to Brussels for a
humiliating extension when voters went
to the ballot box in May the
Conservative Party suffered heavy losses
you're watching boat 2019 the local
elections live on Sky News it's been a
difficult night so far for the two
mainstream parties as voters reach out
for alternatives the cross party talks
with labour collapsed and her own
ministers began openly pitching for her
job are you going to throw your hat in
the ring when there's a vacancy yes in
the end the woman famous the cling-on
was forced to let go it's hardly a
triumphant Premiership and we will never
know what she would have been like if
she'd been given the chance to govern
the country in ordinary times and get on
with the social policies and the other
policies that's really interesting but
she should be regarded as probably the
unluckiest Prime Minister we've had I
think she was ill treated by events and
I'm afraid ill treated by some of her
colleagues as well now the issue that
split the Conservative Party for 40
years
cost them their second prime minister in
less than three safety rich sky news